you know a protein is not really a
protein now what am I talking about a
protein is not a protein
there's a few confusions related to this
topic that I want to clear up because I
keep running into them over and over and
over the first one relates to protein
requirements okay
so typically the minimum requirement of
protein that you need per day
on average it's like 50 grams now the
formula for that which can cause this
number to vary is like 0.8
to 1 gram of protein per your kilogram
weight your body weight here's where the
confusion lies let's take a beef steak
okay you get a hundred grams of this
beef steak which is about 3.5 ounces and
so here you are going to eat the steak
100 grams and you're thinking wow I'm
getting
double the amount that I really need
right now because there's two things we
have the weight of the
steak okay and then you have the amount
of protein in the steak two different
things because the actual protein in
that beef is only 26 grams not 100 grams
and now you're saying well wait a second
I thought it's kind of just pure protein
isn't it like no
there's some fat in there and the rest
of it is not carbs the rest of it is
mainly water okay water weight that's
what it is it has a lot of water weight
in it this is why when you freeze dry a
steak it's like paper it's really light
but the point is when you're dealing
with these
protein requirements we're not talking
about the actual weight of the food
we're talking about the protein in that
food so that's clarification number one
the next confusion and very important
thing to know is that one protein
varies
with other proteins in the amount of
amino acids that they have as far as the
quality and and the ratios so in other
words we really don't have a requirement
for protein at all
we have a requirement for the amino
acids in those proteins and that's
important because when you're looking at
labels it doesn't tell you the amino
acids it just says the total protein
when we're talking about the ketogenic
diet it says you need 20
protein okay but again
no one's talking about the amino acids
and the problem lies in the quality of
protein
or the bioavailable amino acids in
protein food that you eat is a huge
difference between
animal protein and plant protein the
absolute best bioavailable protein is
breast milk but that's usually not
available so the second one is eggs
and then meat and chicken
and then Dairy and then way down the
list you get all these plant proteins so
some of the problem with plant proteins
is they have all eight essential amino
acids but certain ones are very very
very tiny okay like leucine for example
leucine is essential to grow muscles and
if you're living on plant-based proteins
you're not going to get a lot of leucine
and your muscles are going to suffer
let's take wheat protein which by the
way is like 80 of all the plant-based
protein comes from wheat very low in
leucine lysine and methionine but it's
protein right now how can you
overcompensate with that well just eat
more of it right well the problem is if
you eat more of it you're going to get
more carbs okay especially if you're
doing like whole plant Foods I mean if
you're going to ask me like if you want
to be a vegan and you want to have foods
that are high in protein what foods
would they be I mean that's really hard
because there is no um vegan food that's
just very high concentrated protein
there's some protein in nuts there's
some protein in soy there's some protein
in grains but there's also a good amount
of carbs so as you increase the protein
you increase the carbs and it bumps you
completely out of keto now I had someone
on my show bring up this really
interesting question about she's a
vegetarian and she has gut issues and
she wants to solve this problem now I
already know if you're doing keto which
she's trying to do and you have problems
with your gut you should probably go
carnivore well that's a little
conflicting if you're trying to be a
vegetarian or a vegan however thank
goodness she's a vegetarian not a vegan
because at least you can do eggs and
that's what I told her to do it is not
easy to do keto on a vegan or a
vegetarian diet simply because now
you're going to have to start consuming
foods that are refined like even refined
protein powders it's so interesting to
me to see these vegan protein powders
and they call them clean protein versus
what dirty animal protein because it's
dirty what about the grass-fed grass
finish animal protein that's that's
pretty darn clean and it's complete the
plant-based protein doesn't even come
close to the quality of protein that
your body needs especially if you're
younger and you're growing child
if you feed a very small child
certain foods without enough of the
right amino acids it can stunt their
growth and so I asked this lady I said
um why did you become a vegetarian she
goes well my whole life I was a
vegetarian because I just can't eat me
because it hurts my stomach I'm like wow
that's interesting
our bodies naturally have a very acidic
stomach so acidic like between one and
three that's close to battery acid we
should be able to digest protein very
easily unless the pH is gone up and has
become a weaker acid and now we can't
tolerate animal proteins especially so
one big clue
of having not enough acid or maybe a
weaker stomach acid is the intolerance
of meat you just can't digest meat you
reject red meat especially so I told her
I said
I think we can solve your problem
are you adverse to consuming animal
products if your body can digest them
and she says no I said good start taking
betaine hydrochloride start taking
maybe two with the meal three four or
five and keep adding them slowly
and then see what happens in a few weeks
I bet you it's gonna certify your
stomach you'll be able to digest the
protein and problem assault so all of
our food never comes as one macro like
just pure carbohydrates or pure fats or
pure protein unless you refine them all
foods come in combinations and when
you're looking at protein requirements
it's really the the amino acid profile
or protein inside that food and if
you're doing like a plant-based protein
and you're deficient in some of these
amino acids the two big symptoms that
you're going to experience are number
one fatigue or lethargy
and number two your mood is going to
drop but unfortunately people are using
more
plant-based proteins a lot of soy
protein and it's messing up with their
digestion it's affecting their mood it's
affecting their ability to generate
energy I mean if you look at uh at least
the US
you know as far as plant-based
we're already at
60 percent plant-based proteins of
course in the form of cereals which have
other carbs but the point is that we're
doing a lot of grains legumes uh tubers
things like that I think the percentage
of animal meat is like 35 so I just want
to clear up a few of these really
important points if you have a small
child or a grandchild right and you
you're shifting them onto food uh from
uh breastfeeding unfortunately a lot of
these purees or these toddler Foods or
these infant formula type foods
are just loaded with soy and these
so-called healthy clean plant proteins
which is going to create a lot of
problems in their digestion I did find a
company that I'm going to recommend to
you if you need it for your toddler it's
called Serenity kids I've never
contacted this company I have no
affiliation but I am just blown away at
the quality of these products that they
use in these little pouches they're
using like Meats from wonderful Farms
where they have like transparency and
they have they put squash in there and
vegetables and bone broth so it's an
awesome product and I'll put a link down
below if you have a grandchild or child
that might need something better than
the what they have out there like in the
baby food where they have just
applesauce or cereals and
terrible the next time you read a label
it says protein now you know that
there's more to that protein than meets
the eye now I have another video that's
a bit more detailed into this protein
requirements and giving you examples of
other types of proteins
and I put that up right here you can
check it out